bueno lo primero es que finalmente la
parte de londres y bruselas se han
puesto de acuerdo tras cuatro años y
medio de negociaciones finalmente el
acuerdo comercial y cómo hacer la
relación futura entre el reino unido y
la unión europea a partir del primero de
enero de 2021 se ha cerrado finalmente
las partes han llegado a un acuerdo que
era estrenado en ambos lados del canal
se esperaba que se llegara a este
acuerdo para poder que no tuviera un
impacto grande en las economías y por
supuesto seguir existiendo todos los
beneficios de ser parte de esta
comunidad en reino unido dirá extensión
se espera una conferencia empresa que se
pueda los próximos minutos 13 la
presidenta de la comisión espera es la
ponerla en terminar su declaración de
bruselas por esto solar a través de
downing se dirá que el reino unido ha
contado sus palabras sobre el break sin
recuperar a su sobre actividad en aguas
en fronteras y en
ha trascendido hasta el momento que el
acuerdo comercial incluye que habría
cero tarifas para los productos del
reino unido que era la gran preocupación
por supuesto la unión europea también
podrá seguir vendiendo sus productos en
este canal sin este tipo de
condicionamientos de aranceles también
habrá que esperar por su precio detalle
se puede entregar los líderes es un
texto de dos mil páginas imagínense la
complejidad en textos escritos
inicialmente en inglés
wasser muy rigurosamente legal así que
es que esta gráfica la round que de
tarde van trascendiendo sobre esto lo
importante por supuesto sobre los
derechos pesqueros que enfrentó
especialmente a francia y al reino unido
en los últimos meses no se había cerrado
la negociación básicamente por eso que
se convirtió en un tema de soberanía
personal y simbólico para el comercio
boris johnson también cómo serán los
apoyos gubernamentales para algunas
industrias
y que está cerca estará la unión europea
al sistema comercial en el que tan cerca
estará el reino unido al sistema de
comercio de la unión europea por
supuesto muchos detalles todavía por
conocente por estos son los tres más los
tres temas que han luchado en las
últimas jornadas a los negociadores en
bruselas tratando de llegar finalmente a
esa luz verde también es un acuerdo que
avanza todos ustedes alcanzan a
imaginarse bienes alimentos fronteras
derechos de ciudadanos comunitarios que
en el reino unido hay al menos tres
millones y medio y ellos podrán vivir
que ya están aquí podrán vivir en el
reino unido hasta junio de 2021 pero
antes tendrán que legalizar su estatus
ante el gobierno británico así que abren
una montón de preguntas y esperamos es
raúl que en los próximos minutos también
sea ver más claridad pero pendientes
entonces también sobre derechos
pesqueros y un tema también
muy importante quiero va a suceder con
escocia escocia hace de parte de uno de
los países del residuo son cuatro y
quiere buscar la independencia del reino
unido porque quiere volver a ser parte
de la unión europea la primera mitad
excursión y colas hoy en ha dicho desde
antes incluso de que se empezará a toda
esa pandemia del fovis que iniciaría a
buscar ese camino legal para
independizarse el reino unido este año
se ha dicho ha sido imposible así que
esperar a que suceda el 2025 por
supuesto si toda esta situación de la
pandemia
permite habrá que esperar entonces
también qué sucede con el coche creo que
estos raúl pueden ser unos puntos
iniciales sobre los que podemos empezar
a debatir y por supuesto a esperando
detalles por qué
imagínense lo que les digo un acuerdo de
dos mil páginas en estricto lenguaje
legal
así es luisa complicado entonces pero le
pregunto cuándo podemos empezar a
conocer esos detalles cuando a lo mejor
se tiene previsto que las autoridades
tanto británicas como de la unión
europea den a conocer estos estos
detalles y el documento lo publiquen
el documento debe ser público
básicamente ahora que un su lado en ese
momento está hablando el jefe negociador
de la unión europea michel barnier un
hombre casado
cuatro años y medio en esta negociación
el reino unido se ha cambiado varias
veces de jefe negociador así que michel
barnier desde el cerebro del arquitecto
por el lado de bruselas sí
luisa muchísimas gracias entonces por
información como usted dijo muchos
detalles por conocer todavía nos quedan
con esta noticia de último minuto que
les recordamos reino unido y la unión
europea- llegan a un acuerdo comercial
luego de meses de negociaciones duras
negociaciones pero finalmente hay
acuerdo y no habrá un break sheet duro
como muchos terminan sobre todo los
europeos